and of course the big release are the
label but no Accord is what Wow mr.
robot season to you is
everyone and welcome to binge-watch your
go to a weekly show for everything to do
with movies TV shows and of course
stream friendly entertainment I am lost
apologist Lucy James the show I've made
joined by leet haxor Dave do it hello
and one punch man tomorrow saying hello
hi guys we're here to discuss the
biggest goings on in the world of
entertainment and boy we're coming right
off the back of Star Wars Celebration so
do we have some stuff to talk about so
the biggest news from Star Wars
Celebration is a mega spoiler bomb drop
by actor jang when who plays a character
called Bayes malbis okay pretty much
ruin the movie by accident but since
we're not dark side jerks we're not
gonna talk about that at all I'm a dark
side Jack I'm not gonna talk about that
at all loosen you notice by that what we
will talk about is the casting of Jung
Han Solo for a spin-off movie all right
i'll give you like five pounds of you
can say his name properly alden
ehrenreich alden ehrenreich so that's
the guy who is going to be playing the
iconic smuggler in his younger days you
might have seen him last in the Coen
brothers is Hell's Caesar he's also been
a Caesar hailed Caesar held Caesar kind
of similar he's also been in Stoker and
blue jasmine and the TV series
Supernatural which I love him a natural
apologist over here that's me he was
picked from 3,000 potentials that's a
lot of young la solos yeah I wasn't he
like the first one to audition I think
so I mean I just feel like you've wasted
the time all 200 2999 mmm potentials so
he showed up as a surprise estamos
celebration and he was said he was very
excited about playing the character he
got too good said yeah and he got to be
on the Millennium Falcon and so I'm not
surprised that he's excited so are you
familiar with him do you think he's a
good actor or choice for this the other
actors just to kind of give you a heads
up that were potentials were miles
teller not quite my tempo exactly dave
Franco who I'm well up for after his
scrubs I wouldn't take that handsome
seriously Scott Eastwood it's her new oh
I was like wait hi god no I'm not
entirely familiar with him
kind of glad they're not picking someone
as like a super famous person like a
dave Franco because I feel like I
wouldn't be able to see Han in him I'd
only be able to see um the guy from i
scrub scrub Oh 21 Jump Street although
miles tell it could be good but I think
of the minute he's he's Jennifer
Lawrence and that he was really good in
one thing and now he's in everything
count again 123 123 123 rushing or
dragging Russia so you do know the
difference some kind of glad they've
gone with more of an unknown I would
have taken Franco purely because I like
him I do love him he's a beautiful man
also he's got like comedic chops I feel
like he can do smack he's got the
roguish charm as well again he's in
scrubs like I keep bringing him up in
scrubs but he's just so funny picture
him standing next to Chewbacca with a
blaster Anna Vasquez yeah it doesn't
work every I you find that clip from
scrubs because it is the best editing
knows over in the anthology movie which
is a spin-off in the same vein as rogue
one doesn't have a name yet by start
shooting in early 2017 and it's directed
by phil lord and chris miller who you
may know from the awesome lego movie
which is although now that's why lego
movie tues been delayed right mm-hmm you
know what I and that's fine with me
although you know I hope that everything
is awesome in the han solo movie so some
more stir was news from celebration this
weekend if this one kind of went a
little bit under the radar but i think
it is super cool the more of right into
it the cooler it kind of becomes is that
there's gonna be a darth vader not a
movie it's going to be a story
experience in virtual reality this I not
the killer app not the killer app but
it's it's being made it by ILM xlab I
think that's how you kind of say so it's
all these technical Wizards from
industrial light and magic you've got
sound people from Skywalker Sound and
you also have people from Lucasfilm you
also have magic leap you're like one of
these crazy Silicon Valley ask companies
that seem to have a buttload of capital
despite never having actually released
anything but what they've worked on
before with Lucas is they've released
this kind of like
augmented reality thing we can have like
3 p 0 and r 2 in your living room which
looks really cool so they're all working
together to make a Darth Vader like
let's just say movie for sure but it's
been written by David s Goyer who has
some good writing chops flash forward
yep just done like Nolan's Dark Knight
done jobs that's Chuck cod black ops
Dragovich Kravchenko Steiner they all
had to die telling me to why don't you
[ __ ] understand i maintain semi shops
Sammy chopped I maintained that game was
great yeah I was good um Batman vs
Superman but let's not talk about that
um but he's doing a darth vader sort of
some kind of story do know what it's
gonna be but it is gonna add to the
cannon and you are gonna be a visitor to
the story and you can make subtle
changes I don't know how deep these
change is gonna be but do we not think
right of all the characters North Star
Wars universe everything Vader is here
is it not been done you know what I mean
I kind of think feel like he has been
done and at the same time I feel like
he's the only person you can do for
something like this like you really want
to they've gotta go for a big name
character right yeah so firstly it's on
VR which is kind of uphill struggle as
it is the only way you give yourself a
fighting chance is by putting in a
character that people no one love ya
know I'm gonna buy the blow kun yeah VR
experience how would you like to be
immersed in virtue le with jar jar binks
hey I would actually I would love that
I'm sure you were he's the only
impression that I can do yeah no don't
do it and say yeah but you know so it
makes sense for them to pick Vader and
also if you want to have an interesting
virtual experience you get you know the
angriest most unstable character or one
of them anyways guess a good color right
now messing up the joint um but what's
interesting is it is kind of quite gay
me it's from the sounds with their
keeping stuff on so down low at the
minute so you can pick up things you can
examine things like LA noire like
mmm-hmm you can push stuff you can walk
around as I said you can make subtle
changes to the story but also what it's
going to be is it's going to be like a
fully up
system world was like day-night cycles
and the world is kind of gonna continue
when you're not there worried which is
kind of cool and it's gonna be weather
yeah um so I know we kind of come to
this every time there's a VR discussion
is VR the future of story telling you
guys intrigued by the fact you can make
your mark on Star Wars I'm intrigues
when you said there's like a game
element all I imagined was like a an
operation style game where you're
plugging in bits of Darth Vader when
he's like actually becoming all armored
and plugged into stuff and then when you
touch the size it just goes buzz and
looking like customizes or something
sable see him rock around a new hope in
light bright pink armor it's not gonna
happen for me though is know that well
they have just released like a free VR
kind of experience where you have a
lightsaber so I feel like that kind of
element could be good yeah it could be
like I don't know and yet have to be
very sure experience don't know how much
of an interesting story or memorable
store you can tell in what 5-10 minute
chunks or ever who knows this this seems
like a maintenance game I don't mind a
maintenance Vader game keep believing is
all experience whatever you say I think
it's cool so our game of thrones news
comes from a quite interesting sauce a
day Benioff and Weiss was speaking on a
UFC unfiltered podcast and I let's spill
a couple of things and the UFC podcast
it seems a random places that dropping
truth bombs they said apparently they
cut out of major a major battle scene
from season one and it sounds really
interesting from they were saying
apparently the scene featured tyrion and
the mountain going into battle but the
Tyrian was was following the mountain
and it was all shot at his eye level so
you got to see basically what what the
dwarf sees the towering seven-foot
something mountain and just looking up
and seeing all the carnage but
apparently they ran our money and they
did mention that it's kind of
bittersweet because it would have paled
in comparison to like bow the bastards
hmm but you're a resident book nerd and
you said it was actually quite quite
important bat on the books yeah because
the way they did it in the TV show is
it's the one where Tywin forces Tyrion
to be part the army it's Wayne meets
chez toi beads Braun and he's in the
army and he's on the battlefield but
gets knocked out and that's kind
a bit of a cop-out because you don't
actually see anything whereas in the
book he fights you know he actually
managed to take a couple people down he
does follow he was told he was actually
going to lead the Vanguard but actually
its Gregor Clegane the mountain who
takes charge and he's sort of following
him in so to be able to shoot it from
that perspective and see the mountain
like ripping people to shreds why you've
got all the the clans aren't the clan
army like they're kind of like wildlings
but they already live south of the wall
that would have been so cool and I'm
actually like discovering this now I'm
kind of sad they didn't do it and they
just copped it out the wait is finally
over guys the second season of mr. robot
is finally making its way online in
dribs and drabs so we've got the first
two episodes up on amazon prime for us
to watch right now um but if you guys at
home haven't seen the first season don't
have enough time to watch it I want to
get caught up then dave has put together
an incredible recap of season one in the
right well oh you were there as well
which it was there too so yeah we kind
of there's a lot there's a lot going on
in mr. robot there's a lot of twists lot
of plot lines to follow so i can
remember half of them before i even know
i need them think about watching season
two so we kind of recap them all and
it's perfect way to prep for season two
go and watch that yeah so you find that
i'll put a link below there's also we're
going to be watching the first couple
episodes reacting to them like just
digging in deep like like we love to do
you guys seen us do game of thrones so
i'm gonna be doing quite similar thing
for mr. robot so make sure you stay
tuned to youtube.com slash gamespot but
that's it for this week I'm binge-watch
please let us know in the comments below
what you're watching what you're loving
what you're streaming we'd love to hear
from you in the meantime you can find us
on Twitter I'm at Lucy James games I'm
at a regular day and I'm at two more H
we'll see you next week
you